This hyperbola was centered at 4,2, has an a value of 2, and a b value of 4.
Nice thinking if you got these correct. Now, the key is that y squared comes
first, so this means our hyperbola will open up and down. Remember, too, that k
is this value, and h is this value. H is always with x, and k is always with y.
So, our center is really at positive 4 and positive 2. We take the opposite
signs of the terms in the parentheses. To get the value of a, we just take the
square root of 4, since it's underneath the x squared term. The square foot of
4 equals 2. And to get the value of b, we take the square root of 16, which
equals 4. We start by graphing the ellipse. The ellipse is centered at 4, 2.
So, we go 4 units right, and 2 units up vertically. Now we need to go a and b,
we need to find the four other points on the ellipse. From the center we move 2
units in the x direction, and we move 4 units in the y direction. 2 is for a,
and 4 is for b. Remember that a is always associated with the x squared term,
this square root of 4 here. And b is always associated with the y squared term.
In this case, the square root of 16. Now, we're ready to draw in our dash
rectangle and the two diagonals, so we can draw our hyperbola. We need to keep
in mind that our ellipse is going to open up and down, since y comes first.
It's the positive term. So, we're going to cut our ellipse and them flip these
two ends outward. When we do that, we get our entire hyperbola. Now, let's make
sure this whole picture makes sense. Our hyperbola is centered at 4,2 and then
we moved 2 units horizontally for our rectangle, an 4 units vertically.